tranquillement et puis on va parler
ensemble coutteure lecture avec tiphaine
taille sûr que je vais aller rejoindre
sympathiquement et joyeusement pour les
coups de coeur lecture du jour
aujourd'hui tiffen vous avez décidé de
nous parler de la phobie de la saleté et
des virus pourquoi mais parce que c'est
quelque chose qui est assez répandu en
fait maintenant on fait attention on se
lave les mains on se méfie des gens qui
toussent surtout en ce moment ce quai en
fête il ya la littérature jeunesse qui
s'est un petit peu emparé du sujet et ce
premier livre est dédié aux enfants à
partir de 6 ans alors ça s'appelle la
vie rêvée de monsieur maniaque d'adèle
tariel et de jérôme peyrat à l'étagère
du bas et moi ce qui m'a plu déjà c'est
le premier visuel
je me suis dit j'ai envie de rencontrer
ce monsieur maniaque et figurez vous que
ce monsieur maniaque est très spécial en
fait le matin il se lève il balaye ils
aspirent il nettoie tout après il part
au travail
et figurez-vous qui travaille dans une
usine qui fabrique des produits ménagers
qui s'appelle tu microbes donc en fait
toute sa vie est occupé à chasser les
microbes et les bactéries et pour lui à
chaque chose doit être à sa place tout
doit être bien ordonnée en fait la
propreté c'est toute sa vie il a
vraiment la phobie en fait des microbes
et des bactéries
mais le problème c'est que du coup et
bien il n'a pas d'amis un jour arrive
dans sa vie emilie saut du lit une
nouvelle collègue
j'aime beaucoup le nom de julie imaginez
regarder est là bas elle n'est jamais
tout à fait bien coiffé elle a des
tâches sur sa blouse
elle est un peu négligé on va dire on
est le problème c'est que lui tout d'un
coup il se rend compte qu'il ressent
quelque chose pour elle alors celle
perturbe beaucoup et c'est la base de
cette histoire alors moi j'ai beaucoup
aimé ce livre déjà parce qu'il est tout
orange et alors ça fait un effet très
particulier et puis ces deux grands
aplats de couleurs donc ça vous propulse
vraiment dans ce monde un petit peu
étonnant
les personnages sont très attachants
puisqu'ils ont tous des défauts alors il
ya la personne très négligé la personne
complètement obsessionnel et ces deux
mondes se rencontrent
j'ai trouvé ça intéressant pour les
enfants parce que justement dans ce
monde où on leur dit se laver les mains
ne pas manger ce qui est tombé par terre
voilà ça permet aussi de relativiser et
ça parle de la peur alors la peur du
virus mais toutes les peurs en général
vous savez la peur du loup la peur de
laventure voilà un petit peu sabote sa
de cette manière là
alors je vais pas vous raconter la fin
mais sachez que monsieur maniaque
évidemment va aller au delà de ces peurs
il fini par surmonter ses peurs
évidemment une merveilleuse aventure
donc voilà je vous le conseille c'est un
conte philosophique moderne c'est
accessible aux jeunes enfants et puis ça
permet de relativiser attention les
virus à salt et les microbes
on peut en faire quelque chose la vie
rêvée de monsieur maniaque
voilà ça c'est la première sélection
parfois les auteurs vont on va dire bien
plus loin il utilise cette peur des
virus et des bactéries pour provoquer
d'autres histoires assez surprenante
oui alors c'est très à la mode en ce
moment pour les histoires pour les
adolescents en fait pour ce qu'on
appelle les dystopie vous savez pascal
cc univers complètement créé de toutes
pièces maîtresses sombre et en ce moment
du coup fini la peur de la guerre la
peur des attaques nucléaires etc
pour les adolescents c'est la peur des
virus un con qu'on agite et dans ce
roman là qu'il heurtait de robert munsch
à mort donc est publié chez casterman en
fait c'est cette toile de fond qu'on
retrouve il ya deux lycéens qui se
rencontrent charlie une jeune fille qui
est accusé d'avoir mis une bombe et
harry qui lui rêve d'être journaliste
qui lui une sorte d'amitié et à l'âge
adulte quand ils sont très jeunes
adultes et bien il ya un virus qui
commence à se répandre qui attaquent
l'intestin
une sorte de gastro un peu permanente
alors c'est pas très grave en général
mais ça peut quand même tué c'est un
petit peu comme le coronavirus si vous
voulez que tu vaux sur sûre le club en
général mais si vous êtes un peu
affaibli c'est c'est compliqué
alors harry lui comme il est journaliste
et voudrait savoir d'où ça sort comment
ça se répand et charlie allait elle se
retrouve à travailler dans un labo
clandestins dont elle pourrait faire
partie des gens qui fabriquent ce genre
de virus ou qui fabrique les antidotes
donc si vous voulez on a tout cet
univers un petit peu particulier
je pense que ça plaira beaucoup aux ados
parce qu'à la fois les menaces mafieuses
et les menaces sanitaires l'amour
l'amitié évidemment et puis une toile de
fond sur les manipulations génétiques
parce que dans ces nouveaux labo on peut
aussi choisir de modifier son corps s'il
nous plait pas tout à fait avoir un
nouveau bronzage plus de muscle et
revoilà donc c'est vraiment un futur à
passionnant et sava voilà ça interroge
aussi sur l'émergence de nouveaux virus
et comment on y ferez face parfait
parfait ça va faire votre voisin roman
de la chaire qui va nous faire découvrir
des vidéo surprenante et un court
métrage qui à mon avis va vous scotcher
devant votre téléviseur ou devant votre
écran connecté
je n'en dis pas plus on reste au rayon
livres pour l'instant qui dit monde
aseptisé dit aussi parfois nourriture
aseptisée et contrôler c'est votre coup
de coeur
oui alors c'est une bande dessinée qui
s'appelle jardin d'hiver c'est un coup
d'essai c'est un coup de maître un de
paul rey publié chez sarbacane alors là
on est aussi parti dans le futur il ya
une bactérie cette fois par un virus ou
bactéries qui a ravagé toute la vie
végétale sur terre est plus rien qui
pousse donc c'est pas grave parce qu'il
ya une entreprise multinationale santé
zia qui fournit à tout le monde des
pilules ogm avec de la nourriture prête
à ingérer alors sa fausse a produit même
des plats sains tout fait et y compris
aux restaurateurs
alors les anciens restaurateurs sont
assez triste ans parce que il
travaillait avec des plantes
voilà qui d aider aussi des arts des
aromates légumes
donc il garde cette nostalgie et on voit
qu'en fait il ya un monde un peu
parallèle qu'ils aiment la boule voilà
il y en a qui ont des serres cacher il
ya du trafic de graines mais tous assez
sévèrement réprimées par des milices
parce qu'on considère désormais que les
plantes sont des menaces donc c'est une
bande dessinée très très intéressante
sur sa sueur voilà est-ce qu'on menace
la planète est ce que c'est la planète
qui nous mena sera peut-être on n'a pas
ce départ c'est pas possible c'est les
figures intéressante de la guérilla de
la dictature et de notre place sur la
terre une bande dessinée futuriste et
passionnante d'un village voilà conseil
voilà la sélection l'image qu'ont les
pilules mais bien sûr à retrouver aussi
sur le net pourquoi pas à tout moment si
tu fait vous restez avec nous jusqu'au
bout